all right he's getting surreal now
got drafted
[Music]
all right dwayne haskins signing his
rookie deal yesterday kyle murray also
signed his rookie deal both the first
round quarterbacks both taking the top
15 under contract ready to go time for
some pft props between kyle murray and
dwayne haskins big cat which guy throws
more touchdown passes this year murray
or haskins
i'm gonna go with murray just because i
you know the cliff kingsbury offense i
think murray will start week one i i if
you had to say if i had to guess i'd say
julian haskins also will start week one
but there's at least a little bit more
of a question mark there whereas kylo
murray if he doesn't start week one the
cardinals might be the dumbest
organization in the entire world which
i'm not putting it past them but i would
say kylo murray more touchdowns than
dwayne haskins in 2019.
yeah i really do think case keenum has a
legitimate shot at winning the job if
it's a fair competition week one because
haskins only played one year of college
football he's he's raw still now that
same knock is on kyler murray but if
you're the first overall pick how are
you not the week one starter how in this
day and age how can you not put that guy
under center right away and the
cardinals back up is brett hundley i
think kylo murray should be able to beat
him out easily and you're right the
offense is going to be more aggressive
from a passing standpoint i think that
kyler murray will have more touchdown
passes although haskins had 50 last year
at ohio state and that would be
regardless of records or anything else
if haskins ended up with more touchdown
passes this year than kylo murray that's
something that i think we'd be talking
about come january but i'd be shocked at
this point if murray doesn't have and i
don't i don't know i don't know what the
the over under we i think we've talked
about the over under before with murray
like 27 20 i don't know 23 27 he's gonna
have well 27 was baker mayfield's record
uh i would say he's probably gonna have
23. i don't know 23 seems like the right
amount but it really back to the point
about starting kyla murray versus dwayne
haskins possibly uh being the backup to
start the season the cardinals have to
start uh kyle murray you traded your
first round pick last year you you got a
coach who was not he was a very average
big 12 coach you made him the head coach
where he was probably going to be an
offensive coordinator for usc before
that
and then you drafted kylo murray you
have to start him week one you have to
start him negative week one he has to
play every single preseason game kyle
murray is your franchise at this point
he's got to be the guy going forward
every single week
like you said unless they completely and
totally screw it up he will be the week
one starter and with the cardinals we
can't rule out anything at this point
that's not unfair criticism that is
deserved and earned based upon recent
years in arizona all right more likely
to play in 2020 not 2019 2020 rob
gronkowski or telvin smith
i'm going to actually say kelvin smith
here and here's why because rob
gronkowski i think will play this year i
think he will do the willy play won't he
play for the first couple months i think
he will come back sometime around
november and then i think he'll retire
again i think that will be finally it i
think there's a little bit of football
left in him it felt like you know even
even right after he retired you had the
his agent coming out and saying oh you
know rob might come back he might come
back and so i think he will play this
season and then retire again and finally
be completely gone from football in
2020. yeah i think he is going to milk
this 2019 for everything that it's worth
my concern would be for 2019 does bill
belichick even want to bring him back
would he do something like that would he
welcome a guy back
onto a team that already has been
working and fighting and striving week
in and week out doesn't that disrupt the
whole patriot way when you just welcome
back a prodigal son in late november
early december but you know what if they
have needs and and uh the experiment at
tight end with hoddin's ferry and
jenkins and ben watson isn't working
then maybe you do it but i agree with
you talvin smith more likely to play in
2020 if gronk plays 2019 it won't be
something he does every year where he
shows up in late november he can do that
one time and at some point he's got to
move on with whatever this post football
career is going to be acting or just
being gronk
in various possible scenarios and
settings all right a couple of pass
rushers are changing what stop what you
just said what's the difference acting
or being gronk i think those are the
same thing but you know what he's got
did you see him on the billboard music
awards as a security guard
as a security guard i don't think he
acts i think he just is gronk that's the
beauty of gronk he can go be a wrestler
he can go be an actor but he doesn't
have to do any of it he just has to be
cronk
but i noticed i noticed a craft starting
to emerge as he really became that
security guard in that ridiculous
god-awful sketch from the billboard
music awards i feel like i feel like
he's he maybe he's taking a class doing
a little doing a little workshopping
he's hey i think that he's committed to
it i i think that uh he may be on his
way he may be he may maybe holding an
oscar before it's all said and done mike
florio high on rob gronkowski's acting
career i did never thought i would say
that i also didn't think you'd watch the
billboard music awards but uh that's hey
listen now now i have rob gronkowski up
there with marlon brando al pacino he's
probably gonna win i don't know three
four oscars easily we talked earlier
about the kevin malone john mellencamp
ten thousand to one odds if he ever wins
an oscar what would they be for grog a
million to one ten million to one yeah i
think they're off the board
all right uh who's got the more saxon
2019 former seahawk frank clark who's
now with the chiefs or former lion
ziggianza who's now with the seahawks
i'm gonna go with frank clark and we you
know we were just talking about the
kylie murray dwayne haskins what type of
offense i think this part plays a part
in in the equation here the chiefs are
going to still be an explosive offense i
would imagine they're going to play a
lot of games from ahead that obviously
equals you know the teams trying to come
back in the game drop back passes
getting sacks
i think frank clark will be in a better
position whereas the seahawks you see
doug baldwin's gone i think they're
gonna have to grind out games a little
bit more and uh teams will be able to
run the ball a little bit more on them
so i'm going to say frank clark in this
yeah this question is about ziggy once's
health as well will he be ready to go
week one will it take some time until
he's up to speed in the regular seas and
i just think frank clark at this point
better player he's proven more he's done
more and he's shown that he can stay
healthy and if you can't stay healthy
you can't get sex all right a lot of
talk about the browns becoming the
patriots this week which number is
bigger this year brown's wins or
patriots losses
i'm going with brown's wins i think it
would be
listen
the browns are gonna be on the hype
train everyone wants the browns to be
good the whole story of last year with
baker mayfield and overcoming you know
the coach getting fired and all this
stuff they are a darling story i think
everyone if you have even like a little
bit of a heart in your beating heart in
your chest and you're not a steelers
ravens or bengals fan you there's a
small party that's rooting for the
cleveland browns this year right so i
think they will end up being good not
great but good and the patriots i don't
know
i feel like you can pencil the patriots
in for the same uh somewhere between uh
13 and 3 and 11 and 5 and give me the
browns at somewhere between
seven and nine wins
i look at the brown schedule and i
factor in the expectations and we talked
earlier about how
you know all this talk all this hype
would make what they did last year a
disappointment this year two four and
one through seven games hey we're doing
great let's have a parade two four and
one this year oh my god what the hell is
going on and i yeah the tithing the
titans i i look at that game because
people are going to assume the browns
are going to win that game by 50. and
mike vrable is going to have the titans
lathered up and ready to go think about
the titans they they play well against
really good teams and then they stub
their toe against a team they should
beat i would not be surprised if the
titans give the browns everything they
can handle week one and stun them
they're gonna be thinking hey this is
our our uh our one double a opponent to
start the season
they could lose that game then then it's
monday night the jets have a chance to
prove to everyone that they shouldn't be
overlooked i mean if the browns start
losing games early it could fall apart
that's why you don't want your players
you don't want your any anyone anywhere
connected to the organization be talking
about how good the team's going to be
because it puts so much pressure on
getting the season off to a good start
we've seen this time and again if you
don't get off to a good start it can
fall apart and i look at those first two
games if they come out of those first
two games one and one or worse
all of a sudden there's gonna be a lot
of nervous people in cleveland where
they should be thrilled that they're one
and one through two games but that's not
what's going to be good enough this year
because all of a sudden we've got them
penciled in for division champions and
possible super bowl representative yeah
the expectations have put them a level
above the titans and jets when they
probably don't deserve to be there until
they prove it you are right week one
there's always one there's always one
usually two random games where you think
you know these teams and you're
completely blindsided by it remember jim
tomsula he beat those wasn't that
against the vikings on monday night
football and i think the 49ers won maybe
one or two more games after that week
one is that weird week where you just
think you you have a read on these teams
and and you think what you saw last year
is going to be the same lesson i know
from experience because i always lose a
ton of money week one so you're right
circle that game the titans might be
able to uh you know be a live underdog
there and the browns would be saying hey
how did we just lose the titans i
thought we were the patriots
yeah and it can all just go south so
quickly and freddie kitchen is going to
be the guy who gets all the blame if
that happens we'll take a break
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports